5 25 on your Wednesday morning viewer
John wants to know hey what happened to
the showgirl statues there on Las Vegas
Boulevard across from the Strat
when the city of Las Vegas put that
fancy Arch thingy next to the Strat they
also built a photo op nearby with an
oversized roulette wheel giant Dice and
gambling chips along with two showgirl
statues but a few weeks ago the
Showgirls disappeared
so what happened
did someone complain were they kidnapped
well it turns out it's only Las Vegas
mayor Carolyn Goodman thinking big about
those 25 foot tall Showgirls I felt they
were way too small so they are being
reborn as two new Showgirls 50 feet tall
oh but don't worry about those original
statues they've already found a new home
where Las Vegas Boulevard splits off at
4th Street near the arts district
as for when those twice as big Showgirls
are going to move in near the Strat the
cities Chase Radke's got the perfect
show of his answer he says
coming soon thanks for your question
John buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone and you can join the
driving you crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com